[Music]
I go to it and that's it from irna Riscos
swallowed 56 idea and 15 de Guerra Pé is a
club that has achieved it is Nurse Renata Guerra
L'aquila who in bad reputation and
with F1 not creaking Wei Jin
when they arrive Very bad  millimeters from
now on i passed the lawn place talking is
bianca rinaldi in my classroom nothing to
do with poor is not understanding the
disease better she nor he also saw the
hose in hand
the mexican navy in 2010 through
the imbuí neighborhood and saw the boring speech  proof of
baby income is also field even in
df sérgio even and improved and does not play in
italy that goes on to the finals
[Music]
[Applause]